Joe Biden desperately wants to be cool
with the kids by inviting their favorite
influencers to the White House but it's
causing all sorts of problems the White
House forced to condemn a trans activist
who decided to go topless at the
president's pride month event
that type of behavior is as I said
unacceptable it's not appropriate it's
disrespectful and let's not it really
does not reflect the event that we
hosted to celebrate the lgbtq plus
families individuals in the video
certainly will not be invited to future
events and this is has not occurred
before right this is not this was not a
normal thing that has happened under
this Administration but we've been very
clear about how how we saw this
particular Behavior
the topless influencer is not backing
down
I had zero intention of trying to be
vulgar or be profane in any way I was
simply living in Joy Living my truth and
existing in my body
but sadly this isn't the first time the
White House got burned by the
influencers
the day in my life as a White House
intern hey Jenny I booked you a nail
appointment love yeah I didn't tell you
to do that it's called initiative hi
White House is a scooper I don't think
so
ninja don't forget to have fun and me
too I'm here at the White House I hang
out here once in a while I'm glad he's
here I'm glad he's here
so Greg as you know when you visit the
White House there's a whole list of
rules you have to follow about what you
can bring what you can't bring what you
have to do and now there's going to be
fine print that says please don't take
your shirt off and fondle yourself
yeah her breasts are just like the bited
administration fake inflated and built
on Deception
by the way it's not about trance it's
about the artificial elevation of this
noxious uh thing called the influencer
it's it's somebody who monetizes doing
this for the viewers
okay here I go it's about monetizing
their social media following by pushing
products but they build their following
by doing outrageous attention seeking
narcissistic Endeavors it's the turf of
every obnoxious Bozo really I think I
should be doing it but uh so it's like
every time an influencer enters the
picture
everything goes wrong the problem with
the White House is they're too stupid to
know that but it's also a funny thing
that like well number one I wish that
this had happened on January 6th yeah
okay but there would there wouldn't have
been any outrage of course if those
breasts would have been real uh but the
story the stories of trans are out of
proportion to the real impact that issue
has on American lives have you noticed
that it's like we're talking about the
tiniest numbers numbers so small that we
don't even know what they are right
because they're afraid that they'll be
really smaller and you won't have it you
won't have an issue to push but whether
you look at sports whether you look at
bathrooms military beer advertising now
the White House this is what happens
when you elevate an identity beyond the
proportion it merits then you end up
with charlatans coming on and trashing
it just like that and he and she is
living her truth but imagine if any you
know anybody could say they're living
their truth when they're doing something
really awful yeah data for me it's like
it's just not about you like can't you
go to the White House and respect where
you are but I guess if you're this kind
of influencer it is all about you it did
make me wonder if the Bud Light
marketing director ended up getting a
job at the white house because that's
about how bad it was and also what did
they expect Tick-Tock influencers the
way that they get views and monetize is
by being more outrageous than the person
before or the video before and the Biden
campaign announced two weeks ago that
they actually plan to run the basement
campaign with the help of influencers so
I think they knew exactly what they were
doing plus this happened on a Saturday
we don't get the this was inappropriate
until Tuesday and I guess the white
house isn't very proud of all of this
and on the rules thing
in a way maybe you could have some pity
like did no one ever teach this person
that common decency
governs a society
forget like the White House is a special
really important place in American
history and they would prefer to get
likes and Views than to be dignified and
gracious and to be in awe that they even
get to be at the White House what would
you have done if it happened when you
under your watch it would have never
happened
yeah it would have never happened under
Dana's watch
um Jessica there were children present
for this nice viewing portion of the
event uh on Saturday but there was no
breastfeeding so that was good right
I was shocked it seemed like a really
bad look no judgment
um on the surgery itself
um but obviously you're at a very
important event and you're representing
an issue that's incredibly important to
your community so you want to put your
best foot forward on a day that's
honoring people who
um are part of the lgbtq plus Community
but especially for transgender people
who have gone through a lot in their
lives to be able to get to the point
where they're living their truth as she
said it um I the apology could have come
on it should have come right away but
the use of influencers is smart I
understand that this backfired but if
you want to make sure that young people
are getting out to the polls you want
people who they follow to say these are
the politicians that I'm supporting
these are the things that they stand for
and you should be too and I believe that
if there are Republican Tick Tock
influencers I don't there probably
aren't as many as liberals that they're
going to be used by Republican
politicians as much as possible all of
those the college campus kids that we
see on here at like CJ Pearson I think
is one of them it's kind of the same
thing right that you find someone who's
young that connects with the community
that you're trying to go after and you
have them on TV connection should they
have this is a bad connection by the way
don't you find it ironic that you
commend somebody for living their truth
who has fake breasts I mean how is that
living the truth by deception those
aren't real yeah it's a guy that got a
boob job no I mean Jesse's hair that's
he's not living his truth because that's
fake don't you wish that they would have
they probably wished that they had
banned Tick-Tock before this event
but they didn't do it so yeah China got
to see the moves before everybody else
because that's all that Tick Tock thing
is did you just trying to spy app moves
man boobs okay I love how binder says
this is unacceptable but it's acceptable
if this person flashes your children at
a drag Queen's Story Hour they have
books that they
banned in Florida of
transsexuals
letting it all hang out there they're
okay with that they're okay with visit
parades they're okay with this in front
of kindergartners but not at the White
House how is that okay in your kids
classroom or at a drag queen Story Hour
or at a parade on public property but
not at the White House you can't answer
that question it's like I can well you
can okay I'll give you the floor ten
seconds go
people are making decisions about where
they take their kids if they do go to
drag queen Story Hour which is such a
niche thing by the way it's kind of a BS
argument to be making two one not quick
enough this was Hunter's laptop on the
south lawn everybody's seen Hunter
putting chicks in choke holds she's
dangling job offers and cash in front of
his workers this is disgusting
how is that conceivable hunter called
her well this is right after this
because this is not unacceptable this is
totally acceptable for the Bible a lot
of people saw the video and thought it
was from Biden's Hunter Biden's laptop
and also
transphobic is Joe Biden he doesn't
sniff her hair no I think you've got to
say he did I think you did okay okay hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else